[sirens blaring]
NARRATOR: In a post-9/11
world, the field
of forensic science
has become more
urgent and important than ever.
Deaths related to global
terrorism have spiked.
And in 2015 alone,
more than 29,000 people
were killed as a result
of terrorist attacks.
The pervasive threat of
mass casualty terror attacks
demands new innovations
in forensics,
especially when it comes
to how we investigate
large-scale blast sites.
Samples of these
could be taken
and sent for DNA analysis.
NARRATOR: Kim Moran is
an instructor at Arcadia
University who works with FBI
agents, police, bomb squads,
and forensic scientists
on how to best respond
to the aftermath of a bombing.
When a blast happens,
it's so important
to be able to identify
all the victims that
are involved so that
we can return those
remains back to the family.
In terms of personal effects,
people wear very kind
of easily-to-distinguish
jewelry,
so this could really help
identify the individual.
NARRATOR: Debris
from a blast can also
be used to identify
the perpetrator,
a crucial first step in
identifying any links
to terror organizations.
But before this evidence
gets to the lab,
it has to be collected
in the field.
And training for that
is where the challenges
of living in a
radically new world
lead to some radical
new solutions.
[music playing]
I've come to Pennsylvania
to shadow Kim as she takes
students through her
unorthodox approach
to learning the intricacies
of post-blast investigation.
We're in a parking lot,
and a group of students
are dressing dead
animals up behind us.
What's happening?
We have a bus today where
we're sending a charge,
and we have a number of
passengers on that vehicle.
We can't use human cadavers.
Yes.
And this is our
next best thing,
previously-deceased animals.
So these are the
passengers, essentially.
These are the passengers.
Using a mannequin,
it's just not going
to be affected by the
blast in the same way
as an actual biological entity.
It's really important
for first responders
to have really the full
realistic experience of going
out to a post-blast
investigation
with the sights and the
smells and the sounds
that would happen for a
real incident, such as this.
The smells are real.
The smells are very real, yes.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: To mimic real-world
evidence-gathering,
the students create a fake
identity for each animal.
This is Madison Kelly.
Wow.
You literally put
lipstick on a pig.
We did.
NARRATOR: And outfit
them accordingly.
The personal effects
that we're including
will help the
responders positively
identify the individuals.
Some of the stuff that
would seem a little absurd
about what's happening
behind us, that's actually
happening because you are
trying as much as possible
to recreate--
Exactly.
Family members are going to see
something happen on television,
and they are going to
wonder if their son
or daughter or husband or
wife was involved in any way.
What is this?
A sheep?
She's actually an
expecting mother.
Ah.
I knew I hated this one.
OK.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: As the day
swings into gear,
the students load up the
animals and put them in place
on the bus at the blast site.
What are you moving?
I'm trying to move its butt.
NARRATOR: A 3D scanner is
also on hand to map the site
before and after the blast.
It captures a million
points a second as it scans,
and it's able to deliver
a very quick summary
of what happened at that scene.
NARRATOR: But
there's no experiment
without an explosion.
Enter the local bomb
experts, who board the bus
and set the explosive device.
So on one hand, we're
here at the forefront
of a pretty important experiment
in modern day forensic science.
On the other hand, I'm standing
here in front of a school bus
that's filled with dead
farm animals dressed up
in human clothes and
they're about to be blown
to [bleeping] smithereens.
[shouting]
Three, two, one.
[explosion]
[sirens blaring]
To the untrained eye, this
is just pure and total chaos.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The search team must
quickly sift through the rubble
to mark any evidence that
could help identify the animals
on the bus, like body
parts or personal effects--
no matter how small.
From a cigarette butt,
you could get a DNA profile.
NARRATOR: Even a
stray piece of plastic
could be a bomb fragment that
may help identify the killer.
I don't of anything on a
bus that looks like this.
NARRATOR: As the
investigators work the ground,
the 3D scanner provides
a detailed study
of where each piece
of evidence originated
and where it ended up.
Finally, the bodies are
removed from the site,
and the evidence is
collected to send to the lab.
Experiments like this are
really important because not
something that people
see on a daily basis,
but it's going to happen.
We just don't know when,
we don't know where,
so we need to be
prepared for it.
NARRATOR: Because when an
incident like this does happen,
the skills these
students are learning
become the crucial
tools that can provide
critical, real-time answers
to both law enforcement
and victims' families.
[music playing]